that yo it's wild 94 one-minute Ready
Set ready a bootleg have you already
know we got a special show tonight
because we have got the entire wall
listen let's be honest we got two thirds
of the main roster a funk volume in the
building because Jeremy Benton is the
degenerate who probably woke up in some
random strippers bed and Miami and is
running late but we got dizzy right her
and we got hops it in the building
fellas how y'all doing good yeah we're
good
a little tired just from touring for so
long but we're good when's the last time
you guys all toured together cuz I went
on the first I remember that the tour
you guys shot the documentary I actually
got to go to the one and uh I was the
show in Tempe but but once last time
everybody's been together on the road
2012 that was the last time that we all
know y'all tour together every 2012 tour
and that was in a van now you guys have
a bus yeah we had two vans yeah - Vance
- versus yes oh wow who-who's I go on
each bus like who do you Hopsin you have
your own bus cuz you're having obviously
yeah yeah face time with the booth is it
what is yours I always refer to yours as
the we bus but I know you don't smoke I
know you only smoke in the back but yeah
yeah the production is on my bus and it
emerges on his bus okay okay
lots of production meetings in the back
they're very they're very foggy yeah so
this is me Jen and the people work with
the label and one of the production so
I'm curious we were just talking about
this off the air you guys for people who
don't know what tour life is about it's
not very glamorous you guys cannot take
a dump on the bus this is a no we cannot
we cannot I'm pretty sure there are
buses out there I feel like Justin
Bieber can take everyone's I'm sure but
but at this level that we're at we we
can't tell you no dumps on the bus so
what happens you just got to hold it to
the to the gas station
yeah what we usually do we wake up in
the morning and we always ask people I
yell did you take a crap this morning
what you doing that we're which is that
bathroom cool which one and we were just
roaming around the block or the venue
trying to find a place huh yeah yeah
it's like y'all know like yo man if it's
this this brand of gas station we know
they got pretty clean bathrooms so I use
the ohm like sometimes I've skipped like
two days where it's just like dude I'm
on more stage performing I'm like man I
need to go so bad a lot of times those
venues like you know unless there's like
a really fly backstage area like you
know the bathrooms can be kind of know
those old beat-up rock-and-roll acally
tagged on toilets that I don't I do not
want to be on those I'll push it down
yeah
first of all hop I gotta say man the
album I think is incredible I think it's
the album that fans been one thanks I
don't know I know I would I wasn't
necessarily disappointed but I was a
little disappointed with the with the
previous album and I knew that this
album really like it was fulfilling as a
fan I was like this is the Haupt it like
you know yeah yeah really would you feel
that same way like like while you're
recording it because I don't kind of
talk about this on the phone where were
you at mentally for the the album
previous to now yeah why I just want it
home well previously I was just I was
more depressed on the last not this
island just did but the one before that
knock man yeah so I mean it shows a lot
that music I just had a lot of stories
about my life I was just all over the
place this album is home the new one
bounce in the room is just I just wanted
to make a bunch of songs which is dope
beat so it was just kind of me working
on my production in my mixed mixing and
mastering game and all that but um but
everybody I just wanted to make some
dope song suggest vibe to that end which
will potentially set me up for the next
hour the next songs after that because I
really want to just understand
production on a whole different level
I've been producing my whole career
doing all my stuff but I just want to
take it to another level now once I get
back home off this tour
yeah and then you had the big stunt
where you obviously you quit rap yes
very funny the video yeah you and Sharon
was hilarious
thanks um but I feel like it was it's
that was always kind of like something
like like like hanging over the crew
like when I would like to talk to dizzy
or Jer and like it would always get
brought up like you know what's up with
Hopson you know Jan did you did I mean
what brought you out of the funk because
you know I think that a lot of fan I
mean you know you've said things on
Twitter you're very open yeah yeah
sometimes people you might want to get
the Twitter away from hops yeah that is
true that is true
you're like Meek Mill but the
underground social media yeah yeah but
what got you out of the funk man we got
Jeff I don't I said I don't lose Rap
Battles boom but yeah except for you
don't lose rap down yeah but this is
true yeah but I I just yeah I'm just I'm
just open but what was the question
exactly what brought you out of the funk
man they got you like really refocused
on their on the music um we all had like
this funk volume retreat thing last year
where everybody all the Hardison label
we all met up we got like this big ol
mini mansion style house and we stayed
there for like three or four days and we
were all just talking about everything
and venting about how he felt about
everything and each other and what we
how we saw the label where he wanted to
be at and then everybody just came to
conclusion that we decided that we
wanted to do it 2015 tour and you know
if and if we did that to I'm not gonna
be doing the old alright music like that
I want it I want it I want some new
stuff and dizzy and Jaron were gonna be
dropping projects so I don't want to be
like then we got the weak link on the
label it's like I ain't dropping nothing
so it just motivated me to want to
release something as well so I decided
to give it another round and just go
with it
um I mean deep deep down in my - I still
do have I love the idea of me just
disappearing from the rap game and just
taking all my money that I have and just
gonna live in another country are you
even becoming a backpacker and but but
yeah the whole Australia thing like I
just decided it wasn't it wasn't I'm
like I'll still be out there with my
girlfriend and all that but I'm not not
trying to just permanently put myself in
quite rap right dizzy uh the
the position that you've been in is is
you've you've kind of you know put the
most music out I feel like you're always
releasing material when it comes to funk
volume as a label you definitely put out
the most material since you've been
signed to the label what is next the
album came out it was super dope your
second official your sophomore album
yeah I know you I mean you know you've
got studio time tonight it's like you're
always recording bro like this you got
out projects with mark battles and
Emeric it's just like so much music well
what are you working on like right now
cuz I know that there's always something
going on with dizzy right you know are
you dropping another collaborative
project that was going on with dizzy
yeah I got a bunch of [__] but I think
I'm just gonna stand back though for a
second like I had a conversation with ha
he was pretty much saying like you know
you got to kind of drop them nuclear
bombs you know and when they hit make
sure they hit home so instead of giving
them like a full project or just
something little on the side imma stop
nuclear bombs
I'm just working but your arm Derrick's
on the tour right nah he was on the last
tour oh he was honest okay that's right
but what you guys I mean he's I feel
like demyx been around for so many years
and what you guys put out together was
dope what's your guys is like friendship
like and you know yeah it works really
high bro we did a project on a roll we
just got like just like I'm doing now I
got the studio yesterday night we just
go to the studio in the off days and go
up all night we recorded some crazy [__]
we got a bunch of [__] on this low
tape - we got a burner we got beaver up
audio push a couple other guys yeah when
it comes to the tour obviously you guys
are hilarious like dope dudes who is
like the the prankster on the tour
that's that's always given nothing No
begin what No walked up yesterday in a
disguise okay whoo ha I did that okay
that's talked about
but you got a disguise on mustache with
three kind of wigs and because I can't
walk it because sometimes that shows
like a I'm at I'm there and I'm like man
I just want to walk around hangout I
want it but I don't want to be crowded I
just want to be there and enjoy and like
just be able to walk and then just fear
in the crowd in the disguise yeah what
oh let me see what he say yeah yo that's
crazy view I mean people would even look
twice I mean it's only when I was in too
much light then they saw them like oh
that's how that's crazy but yeah because
okay that was I forgot that's I
completely forgot about that I'd let
just let my brain that's the only time
you've done that yeah yeah are you still
playing skate with fans everything every
now and then not only it's not like that
was my thing on the last tour idea where
was like I'm playing skate with fans
every show we like go to their house and
stuff no I've done that a few times just
in my career go go to some people's
house I don't do that too often but um
be I don't haunt play skate as much
because I'm I'm tired loudness no I'm
just sleepy and then I just try to rest
as much as I can and well you got to
take a crap sometime you don't feel like
playing skate you just like man listen
look I've been took it a [__] in two
days yeah yeah like oh I can't skate
right now I'll [__] my pants and then
I'll be on worldstar yeah but back to
the prank thing this guy well he's crazy
he was dizzy would be the most chill at
him no no when he gets turned up he's
turned up he tried to fight everybody on
the tour two nights ago on his tour bus
oh he was he was going crazy
was he drunk him well yes he was wild he
was there with these crowd Lynn Orlando
bro what were you I had an early show on
Orlando - that's what it was see that's
what it was it was that early show and
then it turned into a club and you just
tuck around close beatriz I've been in a
function in the men in it
we just got lit in there in the homies
in my bus kind of turns into like a WWE
match they were going hard as good like
really gosh there's a video him just
like beating each other up like wow but
nobody ever see that are you guys doing
a documentary for this tour
yeah yeah don't the first documentary
how did it do I mean I know it was like
on revolt in in you know oh man's picked
it up and I mean I want to see it on
Netflix I feel like if some [__] still
could be on there yeah yeah a lot of
yeah I don't know how I don't know as
far as like how it did exactly I don't
know the numbers and all that I just
know we made it and put it out that
would be like I did fairly well I think
most a lot of fans see me you know they
talk about it a lot um hop the acting
thing you were in the TNT show earlier
this year he a murderer in the first how
did that show did that show end up like
doing it like like I stopped hearing
about it after a while did it like get
picked up um I don't know if it I don't
know if they picked up for another
season or not um yeah I have no idea
what they did well in it that's all they
know yeah yeah it was a cool experience
yeah it was a cool experience for me
because I've always wanted to just be a
part of a TV show not just add a player
like on it for the whole CA
so as dopes to just see how everything
works and just even me working on what
my skills as an actor just talking to
the other actors asking what they do
because I just got I kind of just got
thrown into it and I'd it came
unexpected cause I didn't plan to be
doing TV show this year it's just the
director hard one of the writers reached
out to me it made a post saying can
anybody get in contact with Hopson and
then the next day I went in and I was
just on the show and it's like man
unless so I just came out of nowhere did
that like spark the put the batter in
your back to do the acting thing again
yeah I want to do it but I also um I
wanna it does maybe want to do more
acting don't why if you just do like a
really bad like straight - straight to
Netflix movie like like snoopin like Wiz
did yeah yeah it's horrible oh god bless
Wiz in snoop but I think it'd be funny
to just have all y'all acting in some
like random like comedy yeah I want to
do the funny as well yeah yeah I don't
like Netflix there's a movie called
white tea about like a magical like
white tea and YG's in it and it's so bad
oh really
it's like it's literally about a magical
like like tall tea like what yeah yeah
but there I definitely want to own
getting acting more uh man I would've
loved what you know would have been dope
that fantastic four movie I didn't know
there's gonna have a black guy play that
yeah and he didn't do a good job
oh yeah I didn't I never get that was a
god-awful movie I it was I would like to
play a role like that though it was like
oh I don't look at the actor too much
but I'm watching the movies I'm just
saying that I've been the Human Torch
and you would've did better than that oh
I'm glad you think so but oh oh yeah
that I would love to be like a superhero
or villain is something that would be
seeing dizzy you are becoming like like
a icon in the weed world yeah guys like
burner who are like entrepreneurs like
to the max when it comes to taking
advantage of all the legalization and
stuff are you like damn dabbling in you
know some investments in that industry
because it seems like oh absolutely
you got you got your whole strain I mean
what do you what do you what do you into
uh in the weed world that you have you
know some interest in that fans can go
out and support and you know yeah I'm
just starting there though with the weed
right now
being on tour is kind of hard to really
get into it but I'm uh putting some in
trees in cannabis cups Oh dope yeah the
next three so we're gonna do Jamaica
SoCal who smokes
I mean you smoking shits on a weed but I
mean who smokes the most weed rapper
why's that you've ever hung out with cuz
I feel like there's like every time I
see where is he smoking every like it
doesn't matter what's going on the guy
will figure out a way to smoke inside it
doesn't matter burners a guy - yeah
burner smokes all the [__] time damn
right damn Rick all the tumeric for sure
damn Rick Kendrick
he smokes burn anybody oh I'm saying who
smoked like I like like who can out
smoke dizzy right is what I'm asking I
guess I don't know
I said nobody no no I don't I don't know
I haven't met with I mean I'm sure they
suppose you haven't my whiz nah that's
crazy
you think snoop snoop I leak out smoke
me
that's probably I'll be real be real be
writin go front I'll be real he'd be
rolling them big ass joint the funky
tips - yeah and that shit's cool but I
I should just be play a little player
blunts or a little joints you know but
sometimes I'll take it there yeah you
know smoke them big ass joys that y'all
yeah the the video you shot with
Bernardin y'all have like a gigantic
like yes that like what do you what the
[__] how much weed was in there yeah
what is that like a what amount of
marijuana did it take to put into that
it was uh foes ifs I think Jesus Christ
that's crazy man
alright well Jeremy Benton still not
here jaren got any questions I can
answer why I am curious do I know Jaron
has a really bad porn addiction so like
what is like the jackoff
what's the jackoff situation on the bus
do you like yo yo guys I'm about to rub
one out leave me the [__] alone how does
that work out well I guess I'm the guy
to talk about that dizzy he talks about
marijuana I talk about jacking off um
jacking off on tour is very important
it's very important to keep your sanity
of course he's a jackoff on tour
especially when you're not getting any
[__] or anything you have to keep your
sanity cuz he especially been out a
bunch of guys do a bunch of guys [__]
all the [__] time you just like man
so I've booked my hotel rooms you order
you do it in the room dude in the room
come I got my hotel rooms um and yeah
get out to every day okay and then it's
up to you to like stayin it or stay on
the bus but obviously you want to stay
in the hotel right cuz yeah y'all want
to stay here so get on the bus
yeah yeah and then yeah how's the like
like tour life we having a girlfriend
that lives in Australia which is on the
other side of the world yeah I mean this
is it's hard I get I'll get to see it
once I once I get off tour but I mean
it's pretty much the same as everybody
else because nobody gets to see their
girlfriend - oh really
yeah and of course dizzy Dizzy's got his
lady - yeah yes and yeah you just yes
grats on the second the second child
yeah so it's a lot of facetiming going
on on that a lot of face time they're
there every day I will look we're gonna
play a record right now uh let's do
hmm we could do the fly record okay yeah
we can do this do that
Hobson the album's out right now Jarren
Benton is I don't know what what what
what is Darin been doing with his life
we don't know who knows but let's do
that we're coming right back
funk volume taken over for two hours
tonight already said radio while 9041 in
the middle of that funk volume take over
you already know what it is man Ready
Set Radio I got Hopson in the building I
got dizzy Wright in the building they're
on tour right now there they'll see they
did Orlando last night unfortunately
they did not do a Tampa show but they
are here nonetheless so they did they
did come through and show some love to
the city I know in hip-hop there's like
tons of acquaintances I always say
there's more acquaintances than actual
friendships but both of you guys outside
of your immediate camp who would you
guys consider like actual friends in the
industry um friends in the industry I
mean aside from the crew like if you
guys fell off tomorrow and like you got
weren't like you know you know if you
guys became [__] cheney tomorrow yeah
you would never happen
I recently I guess I I mean I don't I
don't I wouldn't say I don't have too
many like industry I don't I don't know
too many rappers like that so Disney
would know more than I do I'm I'm always
in my so close
closest thing and this is still pushing
it with home meet me and logic you've
kind of um developed a cool because you
guys first both don't [__] with nobody
if you've seen the logic video yeah yeah
yeah so I saw yeah I met I met with him
yeah it's chilly at his house you know
we um keep in touch and just on a
personal level so we're not it ain't
really uh no like you guys have any
music together right huh you and him
have it no no that's what I'm saying so
it's just like on it's just on on a
personal note you know I don't yeah so I
don't even like address um as as lodging
or anything but it's just so that that
would be but even but we still like we
don't kick it like that but but we do
keep in touch but that that's really I
don't keep me I don't really know any
other rappers to be honest what about
you dizzy oh [__] Logic Pro era factor
Joey was in town last night
yeah what was that it was sold out it
was good yeah it was very very good
oh and tec-9 I'm trippin tec-9 is the
homie homie tec-9 is the homie homie
yeah yes yeah how much did you learn
from tech like like early on cuz I that
was the first time I ever heard you yeah
was I am I psycho that was the first
time I ever even heard of you dawg yeah
yeah so like I know I know that that
song in particular puts you in front of
a whole bunch of new people yeah what
did you learn from from being around
tagging um well the main thing I learned
was to be humble because this dude cuz
cuz when you first come into the game
the perception of a rapper is like you
think you got it you think when you get
there you gotta floss that you they're
like I'm here right now and I'm this and
you better respect it and this I mean
people still respect you but at the same
time you still human so when I first met
him he was just so humble I was like
this is a tec-9 walking in actually it's
a Jaron been walking around yeah Jarren
Benton did you have an all-night bender
last night in Miami oh man did I man
Jerad been just decided to walk in what
was why you late Jarren Benton well
first of all the star with my skin tone
hum black okay I'd like to point out
this year your your friends here in
labelmates are also african-american and
yeah he's right I'm dizzy he's a all the
reason he made it is because uh I don't
know
you got nothing no cuz the Brooklyn goes
up Brooklyn he has it he he's on a bus
with white people so they got him up in
time I'm sorry you you're on the bus
with flick legs not white hey he's not
he's clear are you doing kid man I'm
good man uh well what's up dude house
tour life we already talked about uh how
you jack off a lot on the bus now you
know I don't check my skating I'm just
on a bus uh I got it we're not jack off
I got to be in privacy like I can't even
nobody can be around so I'm the
browser's password I gave you some time
I never thought oh man
what you guys you had a browser got it I
got I got a lifetime password
you really do yeah I got you oh please
give that to me a man that cut that
there's nothing like watching HD porn I
can and I don't know
you know everyone always is like why do
I need it I'm like fan because it's it
it's in 4k much yes that's and then and
was crazy when you see it you like oh
just like I'm there
it really is HD porn is the best I got a
new I got a porn she's not a new porn
slogan who's your new porn star
belladonna I know well see you take the
Louisville Slugger up the ass
holy [__] hold baseball bat right I seen
her when she was pregnant like having
sex with this chick Brooke and Megalodon
is this racist [__] of all oh my god
and I will pay the [__]
oh also Kelly Wales is very nasty do you
know who that is
I've heard of her she's very nest as
well I would pay even the brine is nasty
yo Ava Devine oh and uh who else is a
little nasty [__] I want is uh Julian
Taylor Jodie Taylor's a pretty serious
skin off our skin yeah foreskin gianna
michaels energy on oh my girl ready
already who's your favorite all-time my
point started is you're over there you
got nothing to say about know their
names I always I always want the HD
point subscription but I don't want my
accountants going on and see him all my
than what I've done I'm like man I want
to do it so bad but they gonna see all
this stuff I just stay away from me yeah
I searched I gotcha I gotcha
I got like it has been good for like
eight years okay I don't pay for it any
times it'll like get banned because it's
from its from then yeah yeah it's like
oh they gave that personal password to
you yeah but it'd only be banned for
like two days and it'll be good I know
any porn stores uh yeah there's a few
out here uh yeah you know John a Nicole
who's the new chick that a riff raff was
banging out which I'm not sure if
anybody wants to go near her after after
refresh see you
there's some bad [__] out here in
Tampa that reporters can't believe oh
man we're here Tampa got a day off you
know they all but now we were talking
ously you missed the whole interview for
the most part cuz you're you're an
[__] like but but what's going on
with you Jared
man I'm chilling man I mean slowly
p-value one's dope the [__] album's
coming out
static select them and I will put that
song on the next project you heard it
first here the static selectors got a
song on the project you got a song on a
project what else is going on I know you
sent me some some early stuff that
you're trying on that project with the
homies uh dirty York dirty your club man
that shit's almost done
and uh I'm just working on music now I'm
just gonna start throwing out music in
between working on this new album so the
album is like what percent of finished
I'll be honest with you I would say
thirty percent thirty percent thirty was
in done cato obviously no no Cato
no it is maybe two i'm i'm leaning away
from cato on this one is that like a
personal thing like [__] Kate oh no no
no no it's never personal point I'm just
trying to go with a different sound I
hear you what is the sound I mean I feel
like you have like a good you know I'm
trying to go with yeezus mix with
crystal castle mix with [__] trap
okay I don't know I don't even know what
I don't even know how to take that but
never gonna talk to you guys doing like
an official like funk volume compilation
like I feel like you know tech always
does like the strangulation Joey I think
that'd be super dope we worked we
actually worked on some music together
man and it was gonna happen in well
Hopson well how do you have any hot
those songs in my house we just got it
Dana shut us down he's listen to him
he's like and after they sonicate hahaha
that's what happened please there was a
few revived yeah but it could happen
though it could happen I mean that I
wouldn't say that's necessarily the main
focus get back home but they're there if
we feel like doing it we can always just
hop I know that you are in a critique of
some
garbage hip-hop what is some good
hip-hop that's out right now that you
are liking or feeling if any I like Jake
oh I like Kendrick I like yellow wolf
y'all will find was really good love
story was dope I like big butts and I
cannot lie okay what else do I like see
that joke kicks in it takes like five
seconds but um what else yeah anybody
anybody III do I like Drake Drake is
what are your thoughts on the on the
Drake Meek Mill situation um I don't
really know I mean I don't I don't think
both the songs they're cool it's like
this two worlds is they're judging it
from the like general hip-hop yeah I
like the commercial world and judge
Bryant so as as me being like the
backpack rapper that's in me I did both
both charged up to me was so garbage
yeah you like it was it wasn't I can I
just like charged up I know it was it
was cool like it was cool but if it was
the underground and he made that dish to
like an underground artist see the way I
feel about it is it there hasn't been
any beef records from an artist of that
stature in like long you know I know so
people are hype know people like
literally it could have been anything
and they would have been like joke great
yeah but it but if it was like I but if
it was yeah the way he did it was it was
in a very commercialized way where it's
like it's almost like he did it
specifically so people can chant the
lyrics and know every word to it because
he's worked out for him yeah it
definitely did and worked in his favor
so I mean I cannot understand he played
the game very well on that knowing that
he could accomplish and beat them in
that way but um do you think your fans
hearing you to just say that you're a
fan of Drake are you gonna get like hate
on Twitter I feel like you're gay no no
cuz I've I've admitted to it like I
could acknowledge with somebody's dope
so he's not he doesn't rap like me but I
can't hate on him cuz he doesn't rap
like me and have their aggressive anger
hip-hop sinister dark style like he has
a whole different style but I'm very
aware that he makes good songs like I
you can't like you can't deny that
doesn't matter if you're super dark MC
backpack rap for a commercial rapper he
may
good songs and I can tell even from his
lyrics from the way he uses words and
all that that he he did have the MC
stage like the the that like I guess you
could say how I fly every rapper girls
have listening to like a super lyrical
yeah like you can tell it's there and
then he chose to take the route that
he's taken with the way that he raps and
which is which is respect but I didn't
like him at first but I become more
open-minded and you know I'm aware that
you know music changes and sometimes you
just got it accepted but I don't I do
think he can rap though I don't think
he's like wack Jaron we usually have the
same opinion on hiphop first of all
recipe Sean price oh hey Sean P dude duh
what are you bumping though right now
man Sean P this is what a god I [__]
ordered as a I order from the duck down
site man and I'd be list I've been
jamming this [__] for a minute but um
let me see I'm still bumping action man
um who else I'm bumping huh should i bum
Drake - I'm a Brenda Jules is hard I
mean not really
can I run to Julie if people go back to
my Twitter feed when running juice first
came out this is not a mic it's like to
the grind man you go but you see I was
the first rapper to jump don't run to
Jews and saluted delegate him
the accolades today deserve that was me
I'm just consistent with the run of
juice I'm bumping right now man probably
still a lot of rock [__] man
you know I'm still arcade fighter dude
stays in my place list Radiohead stay at
my playlist who else man I'm bumping
actually maybe kind of [__] up if you
weren't yeah anyway yo uh we're gonna
come back and wrap it up with these guys
I'm gonna let hold up Kim yo I'm just
intrigued what happen if I hit the call
button the mic would would turn off oh
just hit call and then you coffin and
you let go and then it's because you
know yeah because you're not such a bad
yeah you're good it doesn't I mean it
you guys know I mean it's if if I'm on
here and I call yeah with that being
said I probably wouldn't I've never had
a coffee button in my life okay what you
doing man you like you losing weight bro
good doing math oh okay you know this
does just just lots of math man that's
that's but Joe uh enough about my
personal life all right I'm gonna let
you introduce something from the EP and
then what will have these guys back on
and we'll wrap it up funk volume
takeover Jarren Benton just got here you
got a EP that's on iTunes that you could
go support slow-motion EP what do you
wanna play off it man
let me see what I want to play man play
uh ooh play a tickle phobia just because
no no wait what is w WH W let's do it
funk volume take over right here on wild
94 1 its Ready Set Radio man that funk
volume take over live in studio the
whole label - hopper and Swizz this
happens on shortage all right now though
right yeah yeah shout out to hopper got
a real dope project who we got to give
him some love it's hopping friends is
the name I I've been friends in him and
dimmer got a project I was going yeah a
real dope producer but yo man we got
hops in dizzy Wright and Jarren Benton
in studio what is the rest of well I
should say what is 2016 looking like for
the label cuz it's already you know it's
already the end I mean great there's
gonna be a [__] amazing 2016 yeah are
we gonna get a Hobson's album in 2016 no
no you will get you will get a bundle of
hops and songs but I'm not I'm not
really interested in doing albums no
more only because there's the specific
situation that I made I just feel like
my albums get slept on and it's almost
like my my I'm bigger when I release
individual songs and so I'd rather I'd
rather just drop like five or six songs
the year but make those songs big and be
able to tour it because and just enter
strategically plan those songs to where
they can help my help Mike would you do
it mine I know you I know which record
was it that was on the album that it
started off as the new hill mine he said
wait didn't you do something there was a
there was a song we talked on the phone
you said that when you were first
writing it it was supposed to be the
next ill mind of Hopsin but it ended up
just turning into a record on the album
oh oh I thought that was gonna be like
the fly song right that's right but I
didn't yeah but I didn't want to
do them what are you gonna do another
ill mine uh my HS if I've been thinking
about it but I'm just I just have to
think of what I want it to be about
because I don't want to do it and not be
powerful you know so the Romans are
supposed to be something extreme like
really really so if I'm talking about
God I'm really gonna talk about God
talking about society I'm gonna go in
detail sometimes I just don't have
anything to talk about that's that
serious and I don't want to be like
reaching for something that's just like
talk about the birds or some some crazy
or kids starving I mean I mean I could
be the Creator whatever yes I I just
have to I have to think of what I want
to talk about and then just become
comfortable with it and then just start
writing but I haven't I might have an
idea of any kind of thing or something
but we'll see that's what's up
dizzy you've got tons of stuff you're
sitting on so we'll be getting out from
you in the in the new year probably not
probably not probably not but we will
get music yeah yeah I mean they don't
get always get y'all yes
always always yeah I'm just going work
on the best [__] and then drop the best
[__] when uh you know just making sure
TV how's father life man you got two
little ones oh yeah I'm ready to get
back home bro yeah I mean your nuke
you're new to the father life I know
jaren's been a dad for a while
up in the dere is a minute gerunds a lot
oh we won't see how one kids older than
me [__] I think Jarrod's like like 26
no I'm not 26 I had a birthday coming up
tomorrow to your birthday tomorrow is
tomorrow man
well happy birthday yeah maybe if you're
a man 40 yet though you're not 41 ways
away from 40 you're a wait what are you
how are you just tired buddy I'm 34
years old thirty four you know it's
great I never felt never feel like a
shame you like that I don't know what
would be made it like they feel like I'm
proud of my that to change is really old
to transit shoulders of a [__]
they'll tec-9 very old as mo dude that's
why they don't like say they put the
emphasis
he's really all like what you gotta say
really mate they just say I'm older and
I will get a jaren album for sure next
year oh man you go get a goddamn
cheering album you'll get some jam music
I'm just gonna I'm just
oh you're gonna be freebasing with next
thing you know what's crazy bro I've
been thinking about putting out another
I'm just not in that space I'm gonna do
it because when I'm in like that she's
just pure ignorance just completely
thank you they're complete ignorant I'm
still ignorant but I don't feel like
displaying my ignorance right now yeah
like I should give them some new
actually smoked crack yes all the time
really I have people come up to the show
want to give you crap not dating I never
tried to get crack but they want to
smoke what me do meth with me there's
always a crazy [__] I know I I mean
there's got to be you guys share I mean
you you guys have some crazy fans and
you guys do share some fans with like
ICP and links yeah yeah how many times
do you guys get offered like meth or
some like ridiculous drugs I get offered
an album or something like in here they
they don't offer it to me I mean it
people offered me a smoke I don't smoke
but nobody has ever offered anything
crazier that I had to do man this
[__] you pissed me off too they
hit a schizo [__] don't get me wrong I
think I'm a little off in my own sense
but I'm not psychotic off right like I
don't think about killing people and I
don't think about crazy [__] like that
you know but um this dude sent media
nice these [__] photos of like this
do it was a dead human being with like
his dick cut off shoved in his mouth
and I'm like well [__] would you do that
yo Jaron yeah your DMS are [__] on
an eye he gets dead people is the
Inzaghi naked girls I can make it girls
don't get it wrong no [__] add a little
girl it's not you I don't know I don't
know I'm like that made me really myself
like them I'm do I give off that energy
let me say [__] here look at these
photos of this [__] dick like yeah
Jesus Christ
yeah all right well Jaron it was nice
yeah funk volume take over in full
effect
and look I'm gonna let y'all close it
out any any last words before you guys
get out of here I'm about to call follow
them on on all your social medias yeah
absolutely oh yeah hey dizzy right dizzy
hit B right does he hit be honest Oh
Hopson son on Instagram so PSI NSO in
and option on Twitter just HOV saying
and for me it's Jarren Benton on
everything that's my first time I don't
send him don't send me no pictures of
anybody dead I want to see nothing
[__] up really just send me women just
send me naked pictures that's all I
should have my D I'm naked fat women fat
you send me a couple pictures long as
I've been clean and you look guilty
bbw amputee that's that's the genre if
you go on his laptop it's all be BW MPT
Jean how erotic I would take those
verses a dude with his dick shove and of
course you would anyway man is to wrap
the phone going to take over coming to
an end
it's wild 94 1 well I 94 1.2 will this
is up boo that kept showing I'm timid
dizzy right there's all right yeah
what's up man
you